مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه وكالعاده نستضيف
في هذه الفقره المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري مرحبا بك سيد فايز لكن في البدايه
مشاهدينا نطلع على اخر
التطورات ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه
مع الزميله سلام خضر سلام كيف بدات
المعارك اليوم وفي اي اتجاهات واي مناطق
تركزت فيها تطورات سريعه وكثيره ومكثفه
حسن اليوم في قطاع غزه اليوم قطاع غزه شهد
قتالا على مناطق واسعه امتدت من نقاط في
شماله الى جنوبه مع تطورات ميدانيه اخرى
سنبدا من المنطقه الشماليه المنطقه
الشماليه اكثر من نقطه شهدت اشتباكات
واسعه حتى في المناطق التي كانت اسرائيل
تقول انها سيطرت عليها في جباليا لا يزال
القتال مستمرا في غزه لا يزال القتال
مستمرا جنوب المدينه على الاقل وفي مناطق
اخرى هناك ايضا اليوم تسجيل انسحابات التي
كانت سجلت امس من منطقه مثلا تل الهواء
ودوار فلسطين تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من الدخول
الى بعض المناطق واكتشفت فيها في بيت
لاهيه على سبيل المثال اكتشفت فضائع تركها
الجيش الاحتلال بعد انسحابه من تلك
المنطقه طبعا الانسحاب هذا كان سبقه قصفا
عنيفا في الشريط الحدودي عند اقصى شمال
قطاع غزه وهناك دمار واسع في تلك المنطقه
بحسب التقارير طبعا اي الامور لم تقف عند
هذا الحد عند الاشتباكات والكتائب القسام
تقول انها تشتبك بشكل مباشر مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي والجيش الاسرائيلي المتحدث
باسمه ايضا تحدث عن قتال مباشر ومن مناطق
قريبه
جدا اليوم اللافت كان ما جرى في منطقه جحر
الديك هذه المنطقه هي من اولى المناطق
التي توغل اليها الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بدايه العمليه العسكريه البريه و جحر
الديك منطقه قريبه جدا للحدود للشريط
الحدودي اليوم جحر الديك شهدت عده عمليات
نفذتها كتائب القسام قالت انها استهدفت
على الاقل اربعه سيارات عسكريه تقل جنودا
يبدو انهم تم استدراج هذه القوه الى حقل
الغام والقسام تقول انها اوقعت اصابات في
صفوف الجنود بين قتلى وجرحى ايضا
بالانتقال الى المنطقه الجنوبيه الوضع لم
يكن اهدا على
الاطلاق منطقه خان يونس بالتحديد تبقى في
قلب الاحداث اشتباكات على اك اكثر من محور
كتائب القسام فجرت فتحه نفق ايضا بمجموعه
من الجنود وقتلت منهم عددا
اي واصابت البقيه ولكن اللافت اليوم هو ما
اعلن عنه في الاعلام الاسرائيلي عن ان
اسرائيل بدات تتوغل او اليات اسرائيليه من
معبر كرم ابو سالم وهو المعبر الحدودي مع
قط مع اسرائيل يبدو ان هناك امتداد هذا
سياق يمتد تريد ان تقيم المنطقه العازله
ايضا في هذه في اسفل القطاع في اقصى جنوب
القطاع بالتوازي مع ما بداته منذ يوم امس
عند المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع غزه حسن هذا
باختصار التطورات الميدانيه ولكن المزيد
معك ومع لواء الدويري شكرا
سلام من حيث انتهت سلام موضوع الشريط
العازل الذي تسعى قوات الاحتلال
ل
لاقامته هل يبدو انه اصبح اكثر وضوحا على
الارض حاليا يعني هل اقتربت اسرائيل من
تنفيذ هذا المخطط هذا الشريط العازل من
الشمال الى الجنوب ثم
من شرق الجنوب الى غرب الجنوب يعني في
الواقع لابد ان نجري عمليه تقيييم على في
المستوى الاستراتيجي حتى نستطيع يعني
اجيبك على هذه النقطه والان كان هناك
تصريح بالامس وكان تصريحا مفاجئا ب عن بدء
المرحله الثالثه والمرحله الثالثه تحدثت
عن المنطقه
العازله بصوره عامه وتنفيذ عمليات مركزه
اي بمعنى اخر اعاده تموضع قوات جيش
الاحتلال التي دخلت في بعض المناطق هذا
التصريح لم ياتي من فراغ هذا جاء بسبب
جمله من الاسباب من اهمها فشل قوات جيش
الاحتلال في تحقيق اي انجاز عسكري وبالامس
وزير دفاع الكيان طلب من نتنياهو اعاده
توضيح وتحديد الاهداف لتكن ضمن متناول
القدرات والامكانات لان الاهداف الحاليه
يصعب تحديدها هذا يقودنا الى مستوى
العمليات بصوره عامه اذا في السياق
الاستراتيجي هناك فشل ذريع كامل الحديث عن
القضاء على حماس وما شابه ذلك وما بعد
حماس الان نزل الى المستوى العملياتي
الميدان العملياتي الان في القاطع الشمالي
كذلك وصلت قوات جيش الاحتلال الى نقطه
التحول ولم تستطع ان تستمر في ادامه زخم
الهجوم فبدات باجراء عمليات اعاده التموضع
ان انطلاقا من الحديث
عن المرحله الثالثه لكن الواقع هو شروط
الميدان القاسيه اجبرتهم على ذلك في
المنطقه الجنوبيه لا الوضع مختلف الوضع في
المنطقه الجنوبيه بالامس تم تنشيط عمل
خمسه الويه اضافيه في منطقه خزاعه بن
سهيلا عبسان الكبيره والصغيره والجديده
والان بدا الحديث عن محور فيلادلفيا فلسفه
للكيان الاسرائيلي حول المنطقه العازله
السيطره على كافه المحيط من الشمال الى
الشرق الى الجنوب على الاراضي الزراعيه
وفرض منطقه ح عازله داخل قطاع غزه هذه
ترقى اذا اخذنا المناطق الزراعيه ترقى الى
مستوى 50% من مساحه قطاع غزه وهذا لا يمكن
ان يطبق لا من مقاربه عسكريه ولا مقاربه
امنيه لانه هذا هذا هذه المنطقه ليست
المره الاولى التي تتح يتحدث الكيان عن
منطقه عازله تحدث في ثلاث مناسبات كان
اخرها لكن هذه المره عمليا هو يحاول ان
ينفذها عمليا وانسحابات من من الم مناطق
من من بعض المناطق والتمركز في هذه هذا ما
يقوله هذا ما يقول والجواب عليه واضح جدا
في عام 2006 الم يكن قطاع غزه تحت
الاحتلال الم يقم شارون بهدم المستوطنات
واخراج المستوطنين عنوه اذا من منظور
عسكري هناك تجربه سابقه كان غزه كان قطاع
غزه محتلا واجبروا على الخروج ناتي الان
ما هي اليه تحقيق هذه المنطقه العازله
هناك مقاربتين المقاربه الاولى ان اعاده
التموضع تكون كما تسعى يسعى الكيان ان
تكون داخل قطاع غزه السؤال الان ياتي من
جحر الديك جحر الديك دخلها في اليوم الاول
مساحتها 6 يل متر مربع معظم الضربات
المؤلمه اتت من مناطق محدده احداها جحر
الديك هي المناطق التي يفترض ان تكون ضمن
الشريط الع ضمن الشريط العاجل هو خلال
تقريبا ا 55 56 يوم من المعركه البريه لم
يستطع ان يفرض السيطره في منطقه جحر الديك
ومساحتها 6 ك متر مربع
3 في 2 م م مربع كيف سيسيطر على 150 م م
مربع يعني لا لا ما هو الخيار الثاني ان
يفرض السيطره عليها وتكون اعاده التموضع
في غلاف غزه حتى هذه جربها سابقا وفشلت
وكلنا نتذكر مسيرات العوده مسيرات العوده
لماذا احد اسبابها الرئيسيه كانت فرض
تغيير واقع مفروض كانت ها المنطقه يعتبرها
بفر زون وكل من يدخلها باستثناء المزارعين
يقتل فبالتالي مسيرات العوده الشارع في
غزه الغاها اذا هذه تبقى احلام يقظه اقرب
منها الى واقع الان هو يحاول ان ينشئ هذا
الشريط العازل لكن باختصار ما قلته لا
يمكن ان اي يستقر في هذا الشريط العازل
بدليل ما يحصل في جحر الديك وباقي المناطق
التيم يحصل فيها قتال مع العلم انه دخلها
من اليوم الاول طيب لو لو انتقلنا
وباختصار هنا الى الى الجنوب ما الذي يجري
في خانيونس في و ولماذا ما الذي يحصل في
هذه المنطقه تحديدا منطقه خانيونس هناك
الهجوم من الجانب الشمالي من كوس فيم والى
شارع صلاح الدين والى المطحنه والعن طاف
نحو الغرب الى ابراج منطقه ابراج الحمد
وتوقفت في تلك المنطقه كان هناك الهجوم
الاخر من الجنوب من منطقه الفخاري وكلاهما
توقف شرق شارع صلاح الدين هو يحاول ان
يفرض تطويق على مدينه غزه وفصلها عن منطقه
رفح وعن دير البلح بت لكن حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يستطيع المنطقه من شرق صلاح الدين
منطقه بني سيلا خزاعه الزنه هذه المنطقه
لا تزال ملتهبه وهناك اخبار كثيره اخبار
عاجله وصدرت عن القسام اي لكن لم لم تعزز
بفيديوهات في حتى اللحظه التي اتحدث بها
واتوقع ان سيكون هناك في هذا اليوم او
الايام القادمه هكذا اقرا افلام توضح
طبيعه هذه المعارك تبقى النقطه الاخيره
اللي هو محور فيلادلفيا هذا ما سا اسالك
عنه معبر كرم ابو
سالم هناك تقدم اسرائيلي ثم تراجع ثم
اعلان انه لم يحصل شيء ولم يتغير شي يعني
ثلاثه ثلاثه تصريحات الجانب المصري نفع
الجانب الاسرائيلي تحدث عن محاولات وهذا
الحديث قديم جديد وال وجانب المقاومه تحدث
على انه اجبر هذه الاليات على التراجع اذا
احن امام ثلاثه اميل الى تصديق القسام لكن
لماذا باختصار لماذا مع هو استمرار
للمنطقه العازله يريد ان ي ان يفصل رفح
الغزيه على رفح المصريه ويتحكم في المعبر
الجنوبي بحجه وجود انفاق او ما شبه ذلك
طيب
ام هذه الصوره يعني هذا هو هو الشريط
المتوقع انه او الذي يطمح جيش الاحتلال
بان ينشئه ويسيطر عليه طيب لننتقل الى
الاقمار الا الاصناعيه الاقمار الاصطناعيه
وصورها تظهر تمركزات لاليات الاحتلال في
مناطق بقطاع غزه وكذلك
لسواتل وضعها في في اكثر من منطقه هل لنا
ان نفهم او ان نشرح هذه الصور يعني هذه
الصور تعودنا عليها ص هو عمليه التموضع
المؤقت يعني هذه المناطق تحدثها كثيرا عن
الصور سابقه وهذه الصور لا تختلف كليا هذه
المنطقه هي تموضع مؤقت تموضع مؤقت بسبب
طبيعه العمليات في امامه هي الان هذه
عندما تكون القوات مهاجمه لا تهاجم على خط
منفرد وبجب واسعه نحن نتحدث عن حرب لا
متناظره حرب غير متناظره حرب في مناطق
مبنيه اذا يكون هناك عمق للقوات المهاجمه
هذه القوات ايقاع حركتها مرتبط بانجازات
الخط الاول من القوه المهاجمه فعندما
تتعثر او تتوقف على هذه القوات ان تتوقف
في لانها موجوده في مناطق مبنيه ويمكن
ومدينه انفاق يمكن للقسام وغيرها ان يظهر
في اي لحظه كما حدث في هذا اليوم وبالتالي
هو يبحث عن مناطق فارق فارغه او مسافات
بينيه
وينش يجعلها نقطه تمركز مؤقت لقواته وفي
معظم الحالات يعمل حولها سواتر ترابيه هذه
اجراها في على اطراف مخيم الشاطئ في منطقه
الشاليهات وفي بعض المناطق في داخل
الاجزاء الشماليه من مدينه غزه وبالتالي
هذا امر اعتدنا عليه وامر لا يغير كثيرا
في سير العمليات طيب بما انك اشرت الى
الموضع المؤقت هل هذا ما حصل في ساحه
فلسطين داخل مدينه غزه هناك هناك انسحابات
لقوات الاحتلال ماذا
فعلت وما الذي انجزته حتى تعود لتنسحب
الان هي هي امتثالا لتوجيهات القياده
السياسيه ببدء المرحله الثالثه بان ال هذه
القوات عليها ان تنسحب الى المناطق
العازله وتنفذ عمليات نوعيه ام يعني تحت
مفهوم الترويع والصدمه عندما يظهر لهم هدف
تدخل هذه القوات الان هذه هي عمليه حسب
وجهه النظر جيش الاحتلال عمليه تموضع لكن
المنطق يقول هي خلاص من معركه فاشله خاصره
هنا هنا السؤال هو ما الذي حققته يعني هي
دخلت وبقيت لفتره من الزمن ثم انسحبت تقول
هذا يعني ضمن
اطار خطه اسرائيليه من اجل التمركز في
الشريط لكن ما الذي حققته من دخولها يعني
هذا السؤال انا اطرحه على الناطق باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي لياتين بخبر واحد ماذا
انجز عسكريا وانا اتحدث امامك انجز فقط
تدمير ارتكاب جرائم وصلت الى الى عملي
تجريف المقابر هذا الجيش اللا
اخلاقي ارتكب من الموبقات الواشنطن بوست
في هذا اليوم تقول ما جرى في غزه لم يجري
في القرن في القرن الماضي بالمطلق ما
تعرضت له غزه من تدمير خلال اسابيع محدده
فاق ما تعرض له شرق مدينه حلب خلال ثلاثه
سنوات نعم حجم الاجرام والتدمير هذا يعني
انت تجبرني على الحديث في اتجاه اخر هذا
الحجم من الاجرام هو نتيجه الفشل ونتيجه
صمود المقاومه لكن السؤال
الدول الداعمه والزعامات التي ذهبت لتوقف
نتنياهو على على على
قدمين كما يقال
منقوص الا يراقبوا هذا النوع من الاجرام
اليسوا شركاء في هذا الاجرام طيب هذه
عمليات عسكريه للجيش الاسرائيلي سبق ان
علقت على هذه افلام هذه افلام يعني اقرب
الى الفوتوشوب يعني هذه اصلا اتحدى ان
تكون في منطقه عمليات هو دخل في اجزاء
واسعه من من غزه وبالتالي لا بد من وجود
مناطق يستطيع ان يمثل بها ويعرض فيديوهات
واتحدى ان تكون اشتباكات حقيقيه هو يقول
ان هذه لعمليات عسكريه في الجنوب في جنوب
ال بغض النظر سواء في في بني سهيله وغيرها
بس انا اقول من خلال الفيلم اتحدى انها في
معركه حقيقيه وان هذا الاطلاق من النار هو
فقط لاغراض تصوير فيديو لاغراض دعائيه فقط
لا غير اتحدى ان ياتيني بصوره قائد بصوره
مقاتل مقابل او بصوت مختلف للنيران التي
تطلق ماذا عن حصيله الخسائر التي اعلن
عنها جيش الاحتلال اليوم مقتل خمسه من
ضباط وجنود وتحدث عن اصابه 44 عسكري خلال
خلال 24 ساعه ع منهم اصاب هذا الرقم
متواضع في هذا اليوم هناك تدمير خمس
دبابات من خلال اعاده تفجير بحشوات لاصقه
لصاروخ جنت كل صاروخ واحد طن تم تدمير خمس
دبابات اذا اعتبرنا ان بها اربعه الطاقم
هذا 20 بين قتيل وجريح اذا كانت بحملتها
الكامله 50 بين قتيل وجريح هناك اربع
سيارات جيب كل سياره فيها خمسه في هذه 20
بين قتيل وجريح مقتل خمسه اربعه من مسافه
الصفر جماعه كتيبه الهندسه ذات الاختصاص
في التعامل مع الالغام تم تفجير احد الغام
بها وقتل منها اربعه اذا جمعنا في هذا
اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من 60 الى 70 قتيل
وجريح في هذا اليوم لكن هو يتحدث جيش
الاحتلال يتحدث عن اكثر من 140 ب بقليل
يعني
145 قتيل منذ بدايه العمليات البريه
ويتحدث عن
472 قتيلا منذ السابع من اكتوبر اعتقد يجب
ان نضع صفر اضافي تصبح
4720 ونضربها في اثنين يصبح الرقم ما
يقارب 9000 وهذا ما تحدثت به بعض المصادر
الغربيه وكن اليس في ذلك نوع من المبالغه
وهل يمكن لجيش الاحتلال ان يخفي هذا الرقم
الضخم نعم نعم لجمله اسباب لانه ال من
يقتل يقع ضمن تصنيفات هذه التصنيفات اولا
مزدوجين الجنسيه لا يحسبوا على الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهناك 29000 مرتزق حسب بعض
التقارير ثم من العائلات من من احادي
الجنسيه من
يقبل مبلغا من المال من مقابل عدم الابلاغ
عن ابنه انه قتل لا يحسب العرب والدروز لا
يحسب ا اذا العرب والدروز في في في اقليم
في لواء جولاني
35% اذا اخرج المرتزقه اخرج ثنائيه
الجنسيه اخرج العرب والدروز اذا من هم
هؤلاء هؤلاء هم الذين احادي الجنسيه وال
اهلهم رفضوا التعويض مقابل عدم الاعلان عن
الوفاه ويتحدث جيش الاحتلال ايضا عن 189
ضابط وجندي اصيبوا بجروح خطيره منذ بدء
العمليه البريه واضح انك تعتبر بان هذا
الرقم انا انا يعني لا لا اعطيها قيمه لا
اعتبرها ولا اعطيها قيمه لانه من خلال
احصائيات اجريتها من خلال المتابعات لعدد
الاليات الدمرت ومتوسط الاعداد واخذت بنسب
معقوله ثلث اصابه تدمير ثلث اصابه شديده
ثلث اصابه خفيفه خرجت الارقام استخدم
قاعده اضرب برقم 10 شكرا لك اللواء فيز
دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي